Firebase is an app development platform
from Google that offers tools and
services for building and scaling
applications it includes real-time
databases authentication analytics and
hosting features in this course you will
learn how to build a mobile app with
HTML CSS JavaScript and Google Firebase
[Music]
bye
hey there lovely free coat campers and
welcome to my fully interactive scrimba
Firebase course in this course we'll be
building a useful shopping list mobile
app which you can use by yourself or
with other people you live with and of
course we'll be using our new friend
Firebase to hook up a real-time database
to our app now what do you need to
already know to take this course well
you need to have a basic understanding
of HTML CSS and JavaScript exactly how
much more on that a little bit later
okay an important thing about this
course is that it's challenge based
which means that rather than leaning
back and just copying the code that I'm
writing I'm going to be giving you a
bunch of challenges to solve alright
there are two ways for you to take this
course number one of course is to take
it here on YouTube and for that you'll
need to set up your own local
environment but number two and my
personal favorite is to do the
interactive version on scrimba and if
you haven't tried scrimba before Oh my
God you're in for a treat you'll find
the link to the scrimba version in the
description below so okay finally if you
enjoyed this course and you happen to
scroll back to this part of the video
then I would absolutely love it if you
could give this video a like and if you
have any feedback for me then please
leave it in the comments below or even
better reach out to me on Twitter or
LinkedIn and with all of that said enjoy
the course
hey there and welcome to this new
scrimba course where we're going to be
building a mobile app using Firebase
don't you find it frustrating when you
want to make some dinner and in the
middle of cooking you find out that
you're out of a key ingredient so now
you got to get all dressed up and go to
the grocery store but wait what other
things did you need to get again yeah
well you see the problem here right now
here's the thing for 99.9 of people out
there making their own app would be an
Impossible Dream but not you because
you're a programmer now which means that
you can use your newly gained
superpowers to solve a problem in your
life by building your own app now how
cool is that alright I hope you're as
excited as I am let me show you what
we'll be building introducing after cart
a shopping list app that lets you keep
track of what you need for your home and
makes going to the grocery store easy
peasy you can even use the app with your
partner family or flatmates we even have
a testimonial here from a Die Hard fan
now let's see how it works all right so
this is the home screen and this is
where you put in the name of the item
that you want to get let's put in
oranges and then let's press add to cart
boom there it is added perfect now let's
add some more items there we go very
nice now when you go to the grocery
store you can just open up this app on
your phone and start checking off items
that you've put in your cart already
let's delete Oranges by clicking on it
perfect now that's what I'm talking
about now I gotta mention at this point
that what we'll be building is not
technically a native mobile app it's a
web app that's disguised as a mobile app
but by using a special technique our app
will look and feel like a native mobile
app and will even be able to put it on
the home screen of our phones both IOS
and Android now the question is what do
you need to know in order to take this
course well you definitely need to have
a good understanding of HTML and CSS how
good you ask well you need to be able to
code this by yourself and if you don't
know how to do that yet don't worry I
got you covered you want to start off
with pair's free course learn HTML and
CSS you can get to it by clicking here
alright now what about JavaScript now
I'm going to show you a bunch of
concepts related to JavaScript now pause
here and read through all of these
carefully if you feel comfortable in all
or most of these Concepts then you're
good and if not don't panic because you
can learn all the JavaScript you need by
taking pairs free Javascript course on
scrimba click here to access it and then
you can come back to this one alright
now that we've got all of that covered
let me introduce you to the hero of this
course
ah damn wrong picture sorry there we go
in this course we're gonna be learning
how to set up our own database using a
popular service by Google called
Firebase so very quickly what is
Firebase well Firebase has a database
which means that users can save data to
Firebase which can be accessed from
anywhere in the world any browser any
device next Firebase allows the database
to be updated in real time which means
that if I make a change to the database
on my device it will be immediately
visible for everyone using the app as
well and finally and my personal
favorite Firebase is very easy to use
which makes it the perfect database for
beginners now before we start this
course I feel like we need to get to
know each other a little bit better so
here's a little bit about me my name is
Rafael super easy to pronounce I know I
was born in India in 1991. then I moved
to Norway with my family when I was five
years old and I've lived here ever since
three idiots is one of my favorite
movies seriously if you haven't watched
it yet you gotta see it I absolutely
adore butter chicken with garlic naan of
course and finally the thing I love the
most in this world apart from my wife of
course is technology learning about it
and especially sharing what I know with
others so I hope you're ready to start
this course with me make sure to grab
your favorite drink I'll do the same and
let's get coding
okay so what's the first step I've
actually gone ahead and set up the basic
HTML for us to get started faster so we
have an input field here with an ID and
a placeholder and then we have a button
here as well which you can see right
here let's run that yep that's working
and then we have just a little bit of
CSS here just to take care of the margin
and the padding now let's take a look at
the index.js file so here I already have
a challenge for you because I want you
to make it so that whenever you write
something in here and press this button
whatever you wrote In Here gets console
logged so take a pause here try it out
for yourself and I'll be with you very
soon good luck
okay I hope that wasn't too bad let's
take a look at it together so the first
thing we want to do of course is to find
a way to connect what we have here the
HTML elements with the JavaScript so the
way we want to do that is use const
first and then make an input field L
I'll call it short for element variable
and in here we're going to use our
trusty old pal document dot get element
by ID of course and what was the thing
that we named it here let's take a look
here input field
so we'll say input input field right
here perfect the other thing of course
is going to be the add button L and
we'll say again get element by ID and
that I believe was just add button like
this perfect and what is it that needs
to be clicked before something happens
that's the button right so let's attach
an event listener to the add button L
that we just created so let's do add
button L and then add event listener
inside of here of course we want to be
listening for the click event and what
is it that we want to happen well let's
make the function first open up that
with curly brackets and inside of here I
always just like to make sure that
things are working by just doing a very
simple it works console log let's try
that out now
run and click it works perfect okay
what's the next step now so we gotta get
whatever value is entered in the input
field when the button is pressed okay so
I know for sure that I'm going to need
this because this is where all that data
is saved right
so I'm going to put that in here
and first just console log that let's
try that first run and console log that
console logs the entire HTML right so
what is it that we want from that well
we don't want the HTML of course we want
the value that is entered and so here we
can use dot value this method that gets
us the value so let's try it out now run
this again and I'm going to go in here
and say hot dogs
and hard docs console logged perfect now
before we end this I do want to add a
little bit more code here because I just
think that it's much better to do it
this way let me show you so in here I'm
going to make a variable and I'm going
to say that it's input value and I'm
going to set that equal to input field l
dot value and then I'm going to use this
instead
to say that I'm going to console log
that instead there we go
oops get rid of that there we are now
why is this better well it does the same
thing but this is much better because we
know that we want to use input value
later too right and it's much better to
have it defined up here once and then
just use this in the rest of the code so
good job on working on the first
Challenge and I'll see you in the next
one
and now it's time for you to add the CSS
and here you go this is how it should
look so first we got this really cute
image of a cat and then comes the text
input field and then the button and of
course you want to write all of the CSS
code inside of the index.css file and as
you can see here I've added some
comments here that will give you some
information that you need like the
Google font the background color and all
that and I've already gone ahead and
added the Google fonts code right here
now remember this is a pretty big
challenge so give it your best shot but
don't worry too much if you don't get it
exactly right so pause the scrim here do
the challenge and I'll be back in just a
few moments good luck
and we're back I hope that went well
let's have a look at it together so
first thing I want to do here is inside
of the index.html file I'm going to add
a div container so that all the elements
are inside of the container
here we go
and then we want to add an image tag of
course for the cat let's do assets and
then cat.png is that working let's have
a look
and we have the cat up here perfect or
perfect get it I'm sorry for the bad
joke let's go over to the CSS file
okay let's uncomment all of this first
there we go
okay already looking better okay so what
do we want to start with I'm going to
actually start with the container let's
do container
and I do want to use flexbox here so I'm
going to say display Flex right away
there we go and I do want to set the
flex direction to be column
perfect and then let's do Max width 320
pixels now why am I doing this this Max
width well it turns out that if we set
the max width to be 320 pixels that
basically all devices in the world
especially mobile devices will be able
to show that no problem all right so
what's next let's Center this container
so I'm going to use margin for that
let's do margin
20 pixels Auto Maybe
let's put a little bit more there 30
pixels okay
looking better now let's fix up this
image first so let's go in here and
Target the image
and then we're gonna do with
150 pixels much better and then of
course again use margin here to Center
that as well perfect now let's take care
of the input field and the button and as
you can see here they both look very
similar so we can do some copy pasting
here
so let me start with the text input
field first okay let's get rid of the
Border first zero perfect and then let's
add some padding
15 pixels perhaps okay that's looking
pretty good now we do want to border
radius as well and what we want to do
here are five maybe
that's a little bit too little maybe do
eight instead okay looking better now we
do want to increase the font size too so
let's do font size I'm going to do 20
pixels all right that's looking pretty
good now now what else is there we do
want to Center the text so let's do text
align Center and then of course we want
to apply the Google font turns out you
have to manually do it for the texting
field and the button it's not good
enough to put it here a bummer but
that's how it is let's copy that and put
that in right there awesome okay I think
it's looking pretty good so I'm gonna
actually go ahead and copy all of this
and paste that in right here and of
course now it looks pretty much
identical to this now I'm going to get
rid of these two
and there we go see that's all what was
needed now we do want to add some
spacing here between these two elements
and perhaps this element too so why
don't we pick the middle element which
is the input field of course and add a
little bit of margin top and bottom so
let's do
um 10 pixels
that's looking pretty good now let's
make it a little bit smaller here and
compare it is it looking good yes it's
looking pretty much identical so awesome
job now we're done with most of the CSS
and we can focus on the JavaScript I'll
see you in the next Square
alrighty in this scrim we're going to be
setting up our very first Firebase
real-time database I don't know about
you but I am super excited about this
because this is where we take our
projects to the next level a database is
going to give us the ability to save
data that can be accessed by anyone in
the world so the first step of course is
to head over to the Firebase console
click this link to open it up on your
site once you're there make sure that
you sign in using your Google account if
you don't have one you have to create
one okay once you're logged in you'll
see this press create a project then you
can name the project playground check
off these two things and press continue
we don't need Google analytics for this
project so just disable it and press
create project it's going to take a
couple of seconds and it's going to set
up the project for you once it's done
press continue it's going to take you to
your console now on the left side you'll
see real-time database click on that
then press on create database it's going
to ask you which location do you want to
go for pick the one that is closest to
you I'm gonna go for Belgium
then it's going to ask you do you want
to set the database in locked mode or
test mode we're going to go for test
mode now so choose that and press enable
and there we go we have our real-time
database set up now the final step is to
go over here and press on this icon to
copy the database reference URL which
we're going to use in just a little bit
alright so let me show you the app that
I have here this is called real time and
it's just a simple movie app where you
can add the movies that you want to
watch with someone together pretty
stupid I know but it'll illustrate the
point so the first thing I'm going to go
is go all the way up here
and make a const and say app settings
I'm going to set this equal to be an
object and in there I'm going to say
database URL and that I'm going to set
to the string that I just copied from
Firebase remember your database
reference URL paste that in here let's
minimize the browser there we are
perfect now going forward you have to
make sure that whenever I give you
challenges or you're running the code on
your end you need to make sure that this
is replaced with your specific database
URL otherwise you'll be writing to my
database and that's not a good thing
because imagine thousands and thousands
of students writing to the same little
database that's going to be pretty
chaotic so just remember that going
forward okay so what's next now in order
to use Firebase we need to use some code
that lives on firebase's servers so how
do we do that exactly so let's look at a
very simple example that I have set up
and then come back to this so on the
left side you'll notice that I made a
file called functions.js let's go inside
of there this has a very simple function
that just adds two numbers together but
you'll notice that it has a keyword in
front export what does that mean well
imagine that I want to use this function
not in this file but in a different
Javascript file how would I do that well
the first step would be to write the
function here and then add export so it
can be exported to another file and then
you got to go into the file that you
want to actually use it in and use the
import keyword first import and then
whatever we want to import we have to
put inside of curly brackets like this
so what is it that we want to import
well we want to use the add function so
we'll just say add
just this right here
okay what next now we have to tell it
where do you get it from so that's going
to be this file right so we have to say
import this thing from and then we'll
say
functions.js so can we start using add
here we actually can and I want you to
make sure that it can so the challenge
is console log add by using just two
numbers pause here and I'll see you in a
bit
all right I hope that went well you
probably had some trouble with it I can
imagine let me show you what I mean
let's go in here now of course you would
think okay let's just do console log and
let's just do add and then one and one
right so this should work
but that actually gives us an error it
says cannot use import statement outside
of module so in addition to this we
actually got to go inside of the
index.html and here we have to say type
and then module this is the only way
this will work now there's one more
thing we forgot we actually also have to
use the functions a JS file here so we
got to say functions.js and both of them
need to be set to module because you
need module to be able to export it and
then import it so both of them need to
be set to module let's try it out now
run that and now it worked perfect all
right back to Firebase I'm going to get
rid of this and we're actually going to
be importing a Firebase function called
initialize app and where are we going to
get it from we're going to be getting it
from this location there we go and if
you want to see what this code contains
just feel free to copy this and open it
up in a new tab you'll see all of the
code there and we specifically want the
function that is initialize app from
this location all right so with that set
up let's go here and make a const and
call it app and for that we're going to
use the initialize function that we just
imported and what are we going to give
it as an argument well see the app
settings here which has the specific
database URL this is going to be the
missing link because this information
here is going to connect our project
with the project that contains this
database so let's do that now let's go
in here and say app settings
there we go and we do want to see if
this is working so let's just do a
console log and we'll just console log
app see what we get I don't know what
we're gonna get
and we get this let's have a closer look
open up the console what do we see here
okay Firebase app all right that's good
and we get the database URL and that's
the one that we're using perfect there
seems to be communication now between
the Firebase database and our specific
project all right so what's next let's
get rid of the console and keep going so
next I'm going to make another const
here and call it database and actually
for this we have to import another
Firebase function and so this time I
want you to import that so time for
another challenge import the get
database Firebase function from this
place right here following the same
Principle as up here pause here try it
out for yourself and I'll be with you
soon good luck
all right I hope that went well I'm
going to just copy this URL get rid of
this
and then say import
get database
from this place right here and you'll
notice here the only difference between
these two is the app and the database
all right with that imported let's go
back here and say get database now again
we gotta feed it some information right
that's the only way this is going to
work so let's feed it the app object
inside of here
there we go now we're getting pretty
close to this being finished there's
just one little thing that we're missing
so let's have a closer look at our
database so this is where we can start
pushing data but before we can do that
we need to create something called a
reference now what is a reference well a
reference in this case is any location
inside of the database and so since it
doesn't have any data yet we're going to
create a reference here called movies
where all of the movies that we push
using this input field and pressing this
button are going to go inside of that
reference if that was a little bit too
technical for you don't worry let's just
make it work and we're going to be
hearing the word reference several times
during this section okay so let's make
another variable here and I want to call
this movies in DB short for database of
course and let's open that up and again
we need to use another function imported
from this place right here so let's go
up here say comma and then ref short for
reference let's go in here here and say
ref now ref takes in two different
things first which database are you
working with you got to say that
explicitly so let's say database because
we got that up here right so it knows
what that means now the second argument
is going to be what the reference should
be called let's just call that movies
all right so is it going to work let's
see if we enter anything here and press
this do you think anything's going to
happen so I already went ahead and added
this code right the input value and then
it console logs whatever you put in and
it says added database but there's no
code here that we've added that
specifically pushes this to the database
we got to do that and for that of course
you probably guessed it we need another
function from Firebase so let's go up
here and say push now watch this let's
go in here and say push and what do we
want to push we want to push the input
value but is that enough no because we
need to tell this function exactly where
we want to push this in the database so
we want to give it the reference first
so let's do movies in DB for that and
now let's cross our fingers and try it
out let's run this and of course get rid
of this annoying thing first now I'm
going to enter in a movie here let's say
three idiots press did that work yes it
did let's have a look and it added it to
the database again if it didn't work for
you make sure that you changed this URL
to your database URL so I'm going to add
Shawshank Redemption
and I'm going to add another movie too
School of Rock
and did those two get added indeed they
did and we got all three of them there
amazing work we finally have our
Firebase real-time database hooked up to
our project great job and I'll see you
in the next one
it is finally time for us to set up
Firebase for our project let's get into
it right away so I want to start you off
with a big Challenge and here it is make
sure to read this very carefully before
you get started and again this is a big
one so please don't stress too much if
you don't quite get it and please feel
free to go back and refresh your memory
if you need to so with that pause here
and give it a go I wish you all the best
and I'll see you in a few moments
okay how did it go if you managed to do
all of that then Bravo let's have a look
at it together so first thing we got to
do of course is head over to the
Firebase console then press create a
project name it real time database check
off these two things continue disable
Google analytics continue project
completed continue now on the left side
let's go to realtime database create
database choose your nearest location
choose test mode and then enable and
here we go we have our database set up
make sure to copy the database reference
URL okay let's dive into the code so
let's head on over to index.js and I'm
actually going to give you a challenge
again so I want you to First import the
Firebase function initialize app from
this place and then get database from
this one so pause here give it a go and
I'll be right back
all right I hope that went well I'm
actually gonna use these comments to do
this
say import there and we want to make
sure that these are inside of curly
brackets
and there we go that's it same thing
here import
okay now you can relax a little bit
because I've given you two challenges
back to back let me take over for a bit
okay let's go back to the Firebase
console and make sure to copy the
database reference URL once we have that
let's go back here and say const and
then app settings make that an object
and say database URL and set that equal
to this database reference URL now again
I have to reiterate that whenever you're
interacting with scrims in this section
you got to make sure to use your own
database URL otherwise as you can
imagine there's going to be chaos inside
of this app alright so what's next let's
set up an app variable and set that
equal to initialize app and we need to
give it some information we need to give
it an argument that's going to be the
app settings that we've set up right
which contains the database URL which is
going to be the key thing that's going
to connect our project with Firebase
alright so what's next then we got to
set up a database variable
that of course uses get database and in
here we're going to pass in the app all
right one last thing remaining here and
that's going to be setting up the
reference so what should we call this
thing hmm let's call it shopping list in
DB
and set that equal to ref now of course
we got to remember to import that from
up here so ref and of course the ref
functions takes in two things first the
database
and then we gotta call this reference
something let's call it shopping list
okay let's pause here for a little bit
to see if this is even working let's
press run
and we get an error cannot use import
statement ah we forgot to do that key
thing let's go into index.html and we
always have to remember to go in here
and say type module
when do we need to do this any time
inside of any JavaScript file where
we're either using the import or the
export or both of them we have to set
this equal to module otherwise it's not
going to work all right let's test it
out again all right we didn't get an
error so hopefully that's working now to
conclude this scrim I want to actually
give you a final challenge let me put it
right here so I want you to use the
Firebase function push to push the input
value to the database so pause here try
it out for yourself and I'll be right
back
okay I hope that went well let's do it
together let's do push and first we got
to give it the reference which in our
case is going to be shopping list in DB
and then we're going to just give it
input value now is this going to work
well not exactly because we haven't
imported push from up here yet all right
let's test it out now so I'm going to
press run open this up I'm going to put
in oranges here let's cross our fingers
and press this button and I see that it
worked for me great I hope you got it to
work on your side as well awesome job
and I'll see you in the next scrim
just a very quick scrim where I'm going
to cover something that I glossed over
in the previous two scrims and that's
security rules now if you remember when
we created a real-time database we chose
to start in test mode now this is a
perfectly fine way to start however as
you can see this message right here says
something important the default security
rules for test mode allow anyone with
your database reference to view edit and
delete all data in your database for the
next 30 days now what that means is is
that reading and writing to the database
can be done by anyone starting when you
created the database and until the next
30 days which means whatever the time is
at this moment in time denoted by now
here must be less than this long and
weird number now this is just one way to
represent time in programming it's
called Unix Epoch time and if you'd like
to play around with it you can just go
to epochconverter.com or click here but
Firebase is being held helpful here and
giving us this as a comment which you
can see is the 10th of February 2023
while it's definitely past that date now
which means that we won't be able to
read or write anything to the database
let's fix that so let's go back to our
database and as you can see up here
you'll see rules in the menu let's click
on that there we go so as you can see
here there are two rules one for read
and one for right now just click
anywhere here to edit the text now you
want to go ahead and change both of them
to True remember the comma in between so
this means that anyone can read and
write to the database now is this a
perfect scenario absolutely not because
it means that literally anyone can write
to your database however if you're only
using this app by yourself or just with
a couple of other people in your life
then it doesn't need to be a problem
because you'll only be sharing your app
URL with those people so let's go ahead
and publish the changes now you'll see
this warning message which says exactly
what just explained but for my database
I'm going to actually set the writing
rule to false because I want to make
sure that my database doesn't get
spammed you know what I mean which is
also why whenever you run the code on
scrimba during this project you will not
be able to write anything to my app so
that's it for this scrim this is
actually a very important aspect of
Firebase and something will definitely
cover in much greater depth in a future
Firebase course with that covered on to
the next one
all right so before we can work on
fetching the database items from
Firebase we need to First write the code
that will actually add the item to the
Dom in other words we need to write the
JavaScript that's going to add the HTML
necessary to show the items right down
here so at this point you've actually
already done this before you've been
using inner HTML to add HTML stuff using
JavaScript so I'm going to give you this
task as a challenge but before that
let's quickly add the necessary HTML
code we need there we go so we got our
UL right here with ID shopping list and
two Li's that I have as examples here
oranges and hot dogs which let's be
honest here are really the only things
you need to survive right let's see if
that works or not run and we got those
perfect okay let's go over to the
Javascript file so I have the challenge
written out right here so you basically
want to make it so that whatever you put
in here and you press the button that
gets appended right at the end here so
pause here and give it a go yourself and
I'll be with you in a few seconds and
we'll look at it together now before you
start if you don't remember how to do
this feel free to go back a little bit
and refresh your memory okay good luck
okay did you get it well let's look at
it together so the first thing I think
about here is we need to connect our
HTML and our JavaScript and I'm going to
do that right up here so let's do const
and make a shopping list element and of
course we're going to use our favorite
method here get element by ID and we
call it shopping list there we go once
that is done I can just copy this
put it right in here
and what do we want to apply to this
thing well we definitely want to use
inner HTML and then of course we want to
say plus equals and this is where I'm
going to be using template strings
because that's going to let us do this
in a very elegant way so let's do back
ticks and inside here first let's open
it up with an Li tag and then we're
going to say input value
close that with a curly bracket and then
end that thing there we go does that
work let's test it out
open that thing up and let's try adding
some chocolate here chocolate add the
cart and it added it right there amazing
did it add it to the database yup it did
that too perfect now before we end this
scrim I've noticed something that I
really want to fix it's a super simple
thing but did you notice that do you
notice that when you enter in something
here and press the button it doesn't
clear the input field and that's really
annoying because we want to make this
thing as user friendly as possible in
fact why don't you go ahead and add that
code pause here give it a go and I'll be
right back
okay I hope that went well so what are
we doing here so we definitely want to
start using the input field element
let's copy that here now what is it that
we want to do to it well the value is
this thing right here right and that's
what we want to reset and how can we do
that well let's just say that the value
should be equal to the empty string that
should work let's try it out run and
I'll add a Red Bull here
and press this
and there we go it clears it now notice
that the chocolate disappeared and
that's because we haven't started
fetching the database items from our
actual database but don't worry we're
going to do that pretty soon great job
so far and let's keep going
okay I feel like we gotta take a little
pause here because you have been doing
an incredible job seriously just think
about when you started off learning with
scrimba you were learning simple HTML
and CSS not too long ago and now you're
making your own mobile app and you've
just hooked up an actual database to
your project isn't that crazy now just
think about how good you can get if you
continue coding how amazing are you
going to be in three months six months a
year five years
truly amazing to think about if you ask
me so with that let's have a look at the
challenges for this Grim so in this one
we're going to be spending some time
refactoring our code it's always good to
pause every now and then to rewrite your
code in a better way this gets more and
more important the more complex your
projects get and it's especially
important when you work with other
developers so here are the two
challenges that I have for you so take
this line of code and refactor it which
means just create a new function for it
and the same thing with this one so take
a pause here try it out for yourself and
I'll be with you in just a little bit
good luck
all right I hope that went well so how
do we think about this well I definitely
want to take the first line of code and
cut it from here so let's cut it from
here and let's remove this as well
and then we're going to go down here I'm
going to make a new function now what do
we want to call this function
I don't know let me just give it a
temporary name
let's just call it hello
and then we're going to paste in that
line of code and now let's think about a
good name for this function so what is
this function doing well it's taking the
input field element and it's setting the
value to be the empty string so it's
kind of clearing the input field right
it's resetting it so I like the word
clear more so why don't we call this
clear
input field l
so clear makes sense right and what is
it clearing the input field L which is
exactly what this is called as well so
that kind of makes sense right so once
we've done this we can actually take
this function and copy it and call it up
here so it actually runs so that's the
first one what about the second one so
let's start off the same way we want to
cut it from here
cut that and then let's remove this
and we want to make a function down here
again I'm not really sure what I should
call it so I'm just going to call it
hello for now
and then in here let's paste in the
function there we go oops there we are
now let's think about what this function
is doing
so this one takes the shopping list
element uses the inner HTML to append
the input value at the very bottom okay
okay so what element is it that it's
changing is changing the shopping list L
alright so it's appending a new item to
the shopping list L let's just write
that out so I'm going to go with append
item two and I'm just going to copy this
and paste it in there and of course
we're using camel case here so I want to
turn this into a capital S let's see how
that sounds append item to shopping list
L is that a super long function name
kind of is that a problem no I don't
really see a problem with this it's a
pretty good function name if you ask me
let's go with it now is this going to
work let's copy this up here
and then try to run it
let's run that let's see red does that
work
it's not working because it's giving us
input values not defined of course what
do we have here we have the input value
does that mean anything inside of this
function no this is coming from up here
right that's the one so we got to use a
parameter in this case so why don't we
go in here and say that we're going to
feed it the input value whatever that
happens to be and then in here we're
going to create a parameter and let's
just call it item value
and I'm going to take that one instead
and use that in here all right so let's
try that again now
let's do bread once more
is that going to work there we go now it
works perfect now next up we're going to
be looking at how to fetch items from
the database and do that in real time
however before we can do that we need to
go on a tiny little tangent here so that
we can learn about something that we
really need to know and that is how to
take a JavaScript object and transform
it into an array okay see you in the
next one
so much of coding is about turning a
piece of data in a specific format to
another format as programmers we need to
do that all the time so let's have a
look at what kind of data we have here
so here we have a let variable called
scrimba users that is an object that
contains three users the key is the ID
of the user and then the value is the
email address now what if we wanted to
turn this object into an array now you
might be asking yourself why would we
even want to do that in the first place
well think about it maybe you want to
write a for Loop and you prefer to work
with arrays okay so how do you do that
exactly well in this case it turns out
that the awesome people that contribute
to the JavaScript language already
thought about this in JavaScript we have
an object type and you can get to it by
writing object with a capital O now we
don't need to worry too much about what
types are exactly at this point what we
are interested in right now is how to
use a method on object so we can convert
this object into an array all right let
me show you so what we want to do here
is say object and then Dot and then I'm
going to write values
okay and this is a method of course so
we gotta end it with these parentheses
and we can also feed in the object that
we want to use here so I'm going to take
this copy it and put it right here now
of course we do want to console log this
so let's do console log
right here
and let's see what we get run
and we get an array let's have a closer
look yes it is indeed an array and we
get all the email addresses this is
perfect now what if you wanted the keys
instead what if you didn't want the
values but the keys well of course we
have that too so for that we just change
values into Keys let's run that again
and there you go you got the keys and
then of course naturally you're probably
thinking okay what if I wanted both well
they thought about this as well of
course and so the final method I'm going
to give you is going to be entries and
this is going to give you a little bit
more complex of an array let's have a
look and see it gives you an array that
contains arrays that each have two
different things in it first the key and
then the value so in this case we get
both all right now before we end the
scrim I want to give you three
challenges to get some practice with
this so I'm going to remove this and
here are the challenges make sure to
read them carefully pause here try it
out for yourself and I'll be right back
good luck
all right I hope that went well let's
have a look at it together so first I'm
going to go for let and then scrimba
users
emails set that equal to object and then
of course the first one that we learned
was the values one right and what does
it take well it's gonna have to take
this one that's the only thing we have
that's the object
so this together now is going to return
us an array let's see if that's actually
the case by console logging it here
console lock this one let's see and it
gives us the emails perfect now once
I've done this the rest are pretty easy
so I'm going to just copy this one
put it right down here
replace it now with IDs instead
IDs and what do we want in this case we
don't want the values we want the keys
so let's see if that works now
beautiful okay the last one
again copy this one put it down here
and then we go for entries instead this
time and of course we want to use
entries like that
let's see
if that gives us the final one
and there we go perfect as I said
earlier on this is a very useful thing
programmers change the format of the
data all the time all right great job
with this one
in this scrim we're going to be using a
magical Firebase function that will make
it super easy for us to get exactly what
we need from the database whenever it
changes in any way I hope you're ready
for it okay so let's spend a little bit
of time looking at exactly what's going
to be happening here so this thing right
here is our real-time database you'll
see this type of Icon pretty often it's
usually used to denote a database and so
here we have a person using our app on
their phone this app uses this database
to store all of its data now this party
right here is also called the client if
you've ever heard that technical word
before now of course the client could be
using any device it could be an iPad
other kind of tablet desktop computer
laptop Android phone doesn't really
matter so let's bring in another client
right over here now this person is also
using the same app which of course also
uses the same database and so let's say
that this client over here adds in some
value to the input field and presses
this button at which point the data is
saved onto the database now we've
already done this but this is where the
magic happens because right after this
action has taken place the database
immediately sends a signal to everywhere
saying that the database has been
updated in fact it does something even
better it actually sends the new data
from the database to all of its clients
now this data at this moment in time is
something that Firebase refers to as a
snapshot we'll be working a lot with
snapshots in discream so just get used
to that word okay now let's have a look
at the app that I've got set up here so
this app is called best reads and it's
supposed to show your favorite books
right under here now I've already gone
ahead and written the HTML CSS and most
of the JavaScript for it already now
before we start adding any code here I
want to show you how you can add data to
the database through the Firebase
console so if you don't already have it
open let me show you a shortcut on how
to do that you can just copy this URL
for the database of course use the one
that you're using and just open that up
in a new tab it's going to take you to
your Firebase base console to the
realtime database alright so I've got my
real-time database right up here the
first thing we want to do is go right up
here and then press this plus button
once you've done that this is going to
appear it's going to ask you for a key
and a value go ahead and write books
right in here there we go now instead of
putting something in for the value we're
going to just go ahead and press this
plus button and did you see what just
happened there this now allows us to
Nest the data inside of the books which
is exactly what we want okay so let's go
ahead and add our first book for the key
we're going to say one and for the book
I'm going to put in make time which is
one of my favorite books once you're
done with that go ahead and press add
boom we got make time in there perfect
now let's go ahead and add another book
go up here and press the plus button
again and then again we want to put in 2
here and then I'm going to put in Animal
Farm one of my all-time favorite novels
go ahead and press add and there we go
we got two items I think that's good
enough okay now let's go back to the
code so what's the first thing that we
want to do well in order for us to fetch
the database items in that magical way
that I was talking about we want to use
the on value function so let's go up
here and import it first we're going to
say on value perfect now what now let's
go down here and start using this
function so how do we use it exactly
first go ahead and just write on value
and then let's open up the parentheses
now the first argument that we want to
give it is going to be the reference
where we want to fetch the data from now
what is that well that's going to be
this one right here the books one and
I've already got that set up here it's
using the reference function right here
so I'm going to go ahead and copy this
and put that in right there okay now we
know where we want to get the data from
now what's next the next argument is
going to be a function which inside
actually contains the snapshot so we're
going to be able to use the snapshot
inside of here okay let's go ahead and
open that up okay so as always we want
to just do a test first so let's go
ahead and console log snapshot just to
make sure that things are working all
right let's go ahead and press run and
hope for the best and there we go we got
both of them perfect now let's open up
the console now you'll notice here that
this is an object and we don't really
want to work with objects in this case
we want to turn this into an array so
let's go ahead and do that okay so let's
make some space up here and let's make a
let variable and call it books array
now how do we turn an object into an
array well we just learned how to do
that right so let's do object and then
values and then inside is where we want
to put the snapshot okay hopefully this
is going to work so let's now console
log the books array instead press run
again and we get something very weird
that I do not understand it does look
like an array but it's not quite right
problem here is that we don't want to
use Snapshot directly we want to
actually say snapshot dot val which is
going to make it work now hopefully
let's try it again run and there we go
now we got that beautiful array with
both of our items in it perfect okay now
this is where I want to give you some
work to do so here's your challenge by
using this array that we just made write
a for Loop where you console log each
book all right pause here give it a go
by yourself and I'll be right back good
luck
okay I hope that went well let's do it
together now let's do four let I equal
zero and then I smaller than books array
of course the length of that and then we
want to do I plus plus super standard
stuff let's open that up and we want to
do console log and then we want to do
this books array but not the whole array
we want the ith item of it right and so
we can also log that okay so let's see
if this works now run
do we get it yes we get both of them
perfect now before we end this I do want
to add something here because I normally
like to do it this way let's say current
book and then put this right up there
first once we have that we can just use
current book in here of course let's
make sure that also works of course
that's going to give us the exact same
thing Perfect all right but we're not
done yet because we don't want to
console log the books we want to
actually show them here and I've
actually gone ahead and already made a
function right down here called append
book to books list L it's kind of a long
one but use this function inside of the
loop so that you can show the books
right here alright so I'm going to put
the challenge right here so pause here
try it out for yourself and I'll be
right back
all right I hope that went well let's
have a look at it together now so first
thing I want to do is just copy this
whole thing because that's what we want
to use put it right down here so what is
this book value here well that's the
parameter of the function and we don't
really have that inside of here so we've
got to substitute it with something
where's that book well the book is right
up here current book so let's just copy
this and put that in there and I believe
that's all we got to do so let's see if
that works let's run that and do we get
it indeed we do we get both of these
here let's make it a little bit bigger
and there we go perfect now at this
point you might be thinking ah great
we're done not so fast because let me
show you what can happen so let's say
that you go into the database and you
make a change let's say that we want to
change the title of this from make time
to make timed I don't know why you would
want to do that but let's just do it to
demonstrate a point here so let's go
inside of the database and what you can
do is you can just go ahead and press
this and it's going to let you edit so
I'm going to do that on my side let me
go ahead and change that now before I
press enter to make this happen let's
see what happens here now okay I'm going
to press enter in three two one did you
see let's have a look what just happened
it didn't remove the first books it
appended it at the end this is a problem
because every time the database is going
to be updated it's not going to clear
any of the first stuff it's just going
to keep adding that's going to be super
chaotic and we definitely don't want
that so at this point I want to give you
the last challenge of this scrim which
is to try to fix this bug now before you
go ahead though notice that there is a
function that we haven't talked about
and that's the clear books list L which
actually contains the functionality that
you need now you just need to place it
somewhere inside of this on value
function I don't know where that's what
you're supposed to figure out so pause
here give it a go for yourself and I'll
be with you in just a couple of seconds
good luck
okay so how do we think about this now
well here's how I think about it so the
on value function is that special
function that runs every time there is
an edit to the database so in this case
we just changed the title of this
slightly and so it ran the entire code
now this is the part of the code the for
Loop that is actually doing the
appending but before that we're not
clearing anything so why don't we just
plain and simple copy this and right
before the loop runs we say hey make
sure if there's anything there just
clear it before you start appending okay
let's see if this works or not I'm going
to run this again now okay again we have
both of the books AAA hold up right
there for just a second this is future
me talking to you after recording the
scrim I noticed that at this point I'm
actually seeing both books on my side
but you're actually seeing a blank
webpage right now with just the best
reads heading now this is due to a
little bug with the scrimba mini browser
but I want to assure you that this is
actually working in fact to prove it to
your yourself you can pause right here
and put in your database URL right in
here and then press run and you'll see
that it works feel free to make edits to
the database and it's going to update
here again sorry about this we're of
course going to try to fix this as soon
as we can but until that I hope you can
forgive this bug so yes indeed this code
right here is what fixed that bug that
we run into now before we end this
really long scrim I want to give you an
extra well done we managed to cover a
lot of ground in this one
alrighty so it's finally time for us to
fetch the items from the database in
real time Firebase is a gift to the
world seriously so why don't we just
start to scrim off with a challenge so
let's go down here and I'm going to give
you a challenge right here so I want you
to call the on value function you're
going to have to import it up here first
with shopping list in DB as the first
argument and then the function snapshot
as the second argument this will get us
started building our on value function
so pause here give it a go yourself and
I'll be right back good luck
okay I hope that went well let's do it
together
so let's do on value
and then open it up and do shopping list
in DB first we have to specify the
reference first so it knows exactly
where to fetch the items from and then
let's make that function and then of
course we got this snapshot in here
and then open this up there we are all
right it's time for the next challenge
here it is console log snapshot.mal to
show all of the items inside of the
shopping list in the database pause here
I'll be right back good luck
okay so let's see let's scroll down a
little bit and let's start doing this so
let's do console log
and snapshot dot val let's see if that
works run that and we have on value is
not defined obviously because I forgot
the most basic thing which happens all
the time so I'm going to go up here and
import that hopefully you remember to do
that there we go let's run it again and
we got our object with all of our items
perfect okay now I want to give you the
final challenge for the scrim let me get
rid of this first
and here it is use object.values to
convert snapshot.mal from an object to
an array and you want to create a
variable for this and also make sure to
console log the results just to make
sure that it's actually an array good
luck pause here I'll be right back
okay let's do this thing let's go up
here and we'll say let and items array
and we'll set that equal to object and
of course we want to use that
object.values right that gives us
exactly what we need in this case
snapshot dot val goes in there and we do
want to make sure that we console log
that just to make sure that things are
working
as always let's run that to see what we
get and we got that beautiful array
perfect great job working on the
challenges I'll see in the next one
okay so now we've got the on value
function giving us the snapshot every
time the database updates and then we've
turned that into an array right here so
of course the next natural challenge is
for you to write a for Loop using this
items array so that's the challenge
pause right here give it a go and I'll
be right back
all right let's do it together so let's
go with four and let I equals zero
I smaller than items array the length of
that of course and then I plus plus
let's open that up and how do we get the
specific item per iteration that of
course is going to be items array and
then the if element inside of that right
so let's console log that
and then we'll test this thing out let's
run that
and there we go we got a full list
that's perfect okay my next challenge
for you is this one use the append item
to shopping list element function that
we made before inside of the loop to
append each item to the shopping list
element for each iteration so basically
when you run this all of the items
should show up here okay good luck pause
here and I'll be with you in just a
couple of seconds
all right I hope that went well so what
do we do here what's the first thing
that we should do well we definitely
want to use this function so I'm going
to just go ahead and copy this
and then paste it right in here
now let me get rid of this console log
and do we have something inside of here
called item value absolutely not that's
the parameter for this function so we
gotta substitute that with items array
and then the ith element of course in
there right so let's see if that works
now let's run that
did we get it yes we did now there seems
to be a little bit of a problem here
because we're getting oranges and hot
dogs up here but these were just
examples that we added in the beginning
so let's remove them now
there we go
let's go back here again try to run it
once more and then for some reason we're
getting bread two times I wonder why
that is but the rest of them seem to be
right actually scratch that that's my
bad I actually was the one who
accidentally added two breads to the
database so let's actually delete it
from the database I'm going to do it
from the console and see if this fixes
itself or not so let's see here I'm
going to delete one of them yes and
there we go okay so it now did it two
times right so we gotta fix that because
here we have everything and then we have
everything once again now at least it
only has one bread so let's actually end
this scrim here and we'll fix this bug
in the next one
okay so in the last scrim we discovered
that there was a big bug with our code
Whenever there is a change to the
database something isn't working right
see we got all of these here so what is
going on here well can you guess what
I'm gonna say now well if you guessed it
I'll be giving you a challenge to fix
this bug then you're absolutely right
pause here try to figure it out by
yourself and I'll be right back good
luck
okay how did it go the most important
thing is that you try to think about it
yourself okay so let's look at the code
together so I want to immediately go to
the on value function and so this
function is running Whenever there is a
change to the database right and what
are we doing inside here we're using the
snapshot to turn it into an array so
that we can run a for loop on it right
so every time this happens this for Loop
is running which kind of explains why
it's continuing to add the items at the
end we're not clearing the items before
that happens right so we got to do that
right up here so how can we do that well
we can just say shopping list l in our
HTML equals and then the empty string so
let's try to run that now
okay looking good so far let me try to
add a new item to test this thing out
now
coffee
and we have a new bug or at least maybe
this was there before as well but we
still haven't fixed all of it yet at
least it was in rendering all the items
now it was just duplicating this one
last here okay duplication what does
that mean to me that says okay there is
somewhere in the code where we can
remove something that is already
happening well this one we can't remove
because this is the key thing that's
that we need to keep but if you look up
here you'll see that we're running the
same function with the input value so
we're doing it two times now so let's
just get rid of this and I think that's
going to solve our problem let's run it
once more and now let's add in Solo
which is a Norwegian soda that we like
here and now it works perfect okay but
before we end the scrim I am looking at
this piece of code right here I actually
want to take this out and refactor it so
I'm going to copy this and instead of
that I'm going to say
clear shopping list l
and we're going to use this one here so
let's take this out of here make a new
function
clear shopping list l
and then of course we're going to paste
that in right here let's test it out
again there we go and let's add
something healthy here let's add in a
salad there we are perfect always grab
the opportunity to refactor your code
well done I'll see you in the next one
so up until this point flexbox has been
making our lives so much simpler than it
could be it's one of the best things
about CSS for sure now let me introduce
you to another feature of flexbox that
is just incredible let's have a look at
this website right here so I've got some
of my all-time favorite YouTube videos
showing right here there's a total of 12
video thumbnails that are showing here
but the problem is that these thumbnails
are continuing along this horizontal
line as you can see by scrolling now of
course this is a horrible user
experience so let's fix this problem by
using something called Flex wrap now
check this out so all I got to do is
tell flexbox hey take all of the
elements inside of this parent's div and
wrap it around the max width of the
parent element okay let's do it now so
Flex wrap and then we'll say yes please
we do want to wrap it so let's do that
and there we go isn't is that amazing do
you see how beautiful that looks imagine
how much more CSS we would need to write
without Flex wrap now before we end the
scrim let me show you two more values
that you can put right in here so the
others would be no wrap which takes you
back to the default
and then there's rap reverse which of
course reverses the order so let's take
it back to wrap and there we go
beautiful
so here we have one of the most iconic
album Arts of one of the best bands in
history written in HTML and CSS of
course now currently we're using margin
right here in order to create some
spacing between the pictures of The
Beetles this right here now that's fine
of course but now we know flexbox which
means that there is a much cleaner way
to achieve the same result so instead of
using the individual elements here to
create a margin we can instead say to
the parent element that you should
create a gap of let's say 10 pixels
between all the child elements let me
show you so let's remove this there we
go and let's go in here and say Gap and
then how much Gap do we want let's do 10
pixels and there you go that's all there
is now let's add some more Gap so let's
do 20 pixels now of course that's too
much because we have a Max width here of
420. we can increase that to 440 let's
say and then we're back here perfect now
what if you wanted to have a different
Gap top bottom than left and right well
you can do that in an easy way here too
so let's say go in here and let's do 10
pixels here so here you'll see left
right is 10 pixels and top bottom is 20
pixels so you can control even that but
I'm going to just let it be at 10 pixels
so let's get back to that
okay this is where we're going to take a
little pause from working on JavaScript
for just a little bit so that we can add
some more CSS as you can see the list
items are being displayed like this
which is the default way but we want
them to be displaying like this and so
that's your challenge to solve now
before I let you work on this I gotta
mention here that you want to put all of
your code inside of the CSS file in fact
I've already gone ahead and added all of
this for you so make sure that you write
your code in between here and here and
there's also a CSS comment here that
includes the background color the cream
color that you can see here and also the
code for the Box Shadow is right here
okay so this is a big challenge so
please take your time with this and of
course if you don't fully get it then
that's completely fine the most
important thing is that you try so pause
here and give it a go by yourself and
I'll be with you in just a little bit
good luck
okay I hope that went well let's have a
look at it together so what's the first
thing that we notice here well I don't
know about you but I noticed that there
are no bullet points here we don't have
that so let's get rid of that and then
of course the items are laid out next to
each other so we definitely want to be
using flexbox and then we want to use
flex wrap to wrap the items around there
is a little bit of a gap here as well
that we want to include okay let's get
started so I'm going to go inside of the
UL first and I'm going to use list Style
type and I'm going to set that equal to
none and there we go beautiful all of
the circles are gone okay what's next I
definitely want to get rid of this space
right here I believe that's the padding
let's see
padding equals zero perfect okay next
let's do display Flex
there we go very nice then let's do Flex
wrap and set that equal to wrap awesome
okay let's keep it like that for now
let's go down here now and I'm going to
uncomment this first there we go very
nice and let's get rid of this line and
add some padding here
how much padding should we add I'm gonna
try 10 pixels first let's see how that
looks looking pretty good but I think I
want to increase it to 15 actually there
we go much better okay we also have a
border radius here of course like
everything else so let's go ahead and
add that right under here border radius
I also want to make that eight pixels
like the others so let's go for eight
pixels right there now is there anything
we're missing as you can see right here
the items are kind of crammed together
so we definitely want to give it some
Gap let's do Gap 10 pixels okay that's
pretty good but still we can see there
is a little bit of space right here on
the right side for this Red Bull item
and I want these to be stretched out as
much as possible we're going to use flex
grow for this so we're going to say Flex
grow
equals one and that should fix that
perfect now is there anything else we're
missing here it's a little bit difficult
to see but you can see that the text is
not quite aligned to the center let's
fix that text align
Center and you know what I think this
looks pretty much identical to this now
awesome now there is one thing that I
also want to change I can see that the
font size right here is smaller than the
one up here I want to see if it looks
better if I change it to the same font
size as the rest let's try that up here
let's copy it from here font size
and explicitly Define it up here so
let's set the font size to 20 pixels in
my opinion this looks better now of
course it's up to you what you like
better feel free to make changes
whenever you see fit okay let's have a
final look at it let's run the app let's
stretch it out a little bit oh my God
this is looking so good this is
genuinely looking like an app that you
would download from the app store is
that crazy or am I a little bit
delusional don't you think this looks
pretty good well that's my opinion of
course this definitely looks pretty
sweet okay good job so far let's keep
going
okay so now our app is really only
missing one feature and that's the
delete feature so we wanted to make it
so that whenever you press on any one of
these items it is removed from the cart
meaning it's removed from the database
right now in order to do that we need to
understand something very important in
software development and that's the
concept of a unique ID let's have a look
at our database so here we see all of
our items listed out here inside of the
shopping list notice that each item is
listed with a key and a value exactly
the same by the way as in a JavaScript
object now what is this weird thing
right here well if you notice all of
these are different from each other
which means that it's a unique
identifier now why do we even have to
have these in the first place well think
about it if you want to delete a
specific item from the database don't
you need to know exactly which item it
is and then you might think well don't
you already have the name of the item
right here yeah sure but what happens if
someone adds the same item twice the way
we've programmed this that's definitely
allowed so we need to have a unique
identifier and that is why we have this
ID now luckily we're using Firebase so
we don't need to worry about creating
this ID for ourselves Firebase does that
automatically however we do need to
figure out a way to get the ID somehow
inside of our code because that's the
only way we can tell Firebase to delete
an item for us okay let's go back to the
code alright I'm going to go inside of
here and I'm gonna use the old console
log trick
and I'm going to say snapshot dot val
that's what we started off with right so
let's do that again let's run that and
see what we get okay great those are all
the items from our database and notice
here we have both the ID and the items
okay so what we're doing here is that
right here in the items array we're
using object.values to convert those
into just the values I wonder if there's
another method that we can use on object
that gives us both can you think of
anything if you can pause right here and
put it in here I'll be with you in just
a few seconds
okay did you remember it well remember
we can use values but we can also use
Keys remember that will just give us the
IDS let's try that by console logging
items array let's run that now we get
only the IDS but remember there was a
third one called entries let's try that
one now what do we get now now we get an
array with smaller arrays inside of it
that contain both the ID and the value
this is perfect for us okay so what do
we do now well we want to access these
things right inside of the loop here so
I'm going to go ahead actually and do
what I always like to do which is make a
variable here for the current item
and in here I'm going to say items array
and then the ith element so we can use
current item here okay so we got the
current item let's see what we get now
let's open this up ah do you see
now this is getting pretty congested but
we got both the ID and the value okay
this is looking pretty good now I have a
challenge for you because I want you to
use current item but make two new
variables call it current Item ID and
current item value and use current item
to set both of them equal to the correct
values okay pause here try it out for
yourself and I'll be right back
okay I hope that went well let's do it
together now current item ID and that's
going to be current item remember this
is an array with two things inside of it
what's going to be the ID well that's
the first one or rather the zero F1
because we're dealing with arrays so I'm
going to say 0 in here similarly we're
going to say current item value and here
we're going to set it equal to one let's
try it out now ID first let's see how
that looks run do we just get the ID
indeed we do perfect let's do it for the
value now run and now we're back to
getting the value only perfect now we
have the information that we need well
done
okay now we have a little bit of a
problem here how are we adding a new
item to the shopping list element well
currently we're using inner HTML with
template strings and while that works in
a lot of simple cases it's not going to
work for us anymore why because we need
to make it so that we can attach an
event listener to all of these items and
we need to do that so that we can run a
function every time the user clicks on
any of these items and that's just not
possible this way so what we need is
create element and you've actually
already seen this although very briefly
in a previous scrim however in this one
we're going to dive much deeper into it
now I gotta give you a little disclaimer
here create element can be one of those
things that's pretty confusing to
understand at least in the beginning so
I'm going to try my best to explain it
to you in an intuitive way okay so as
you can probably guess from the name
create element is a function that lets
you well create an element of course but
it's a method that needs to be applied
to the document object so you can say
document dot create element and then you
have to make a decision about which
element you want to make do you want to
make an H1 a paragraph tag a div you can
make anything and in our case we want to
make a new list item An Li that's step
one step two is to give your newly
created item some text content and in
our case that's going to be the name of
the item all right done with step two
the last step is to place the newly
created element into its parent element
and in our case that's going to be the
shopping list element the UL okay so
let's go back a little bit and start
with step number one so I'm going to go
down here and for now we're gonna just
comment out this line and so the first
thing we need to do is to create a
variable and I'm going to call it new L
and I'm going to equal that to document
dot create element okay inside of here
we gotta give it what is it that we want
to make in our case we want to make a
list item that's step one completed okay
so what's step two well that is put some
text between the tags right so let's go
down here and say hey new L I want to
add some text content to you
and I want that to be something we'll
fix this later we'll just put in a
string here to test it out first all
right what is the last step the last
step is to take this thing that we just
made and place it inside of the parent
element and for that where is our parent
element well let's go up here and take a
look that's going to be our shopping
list L right so let's copy that
go down here and say
start with that and then append we're
using a method called append what do we
want to append well we want to append
nual at the very end
so let's put that in here and hopefully
when I run this now in the mini browser
it's going to take away all the names of
the items it's going to show us a bunch
of items that say something let's see if
that works let's run this now and there
we go it works perfect okay now this is
where I want to give you a challenge
pause here and change the code so that
it actually shows the name of the items
rather than something for everything so
pause here give it a go and I'll be
right back
okay I hope that went well so this is
how I think about it we already have
item value here as the parameter right
so we can just use this and we're
actually feeding it up here using the
current item values so that should give
us what we're looking for so let's just
go in here and say item value just copy
it up from here and replace it
down here
and let's now try to run it see what we
get and we get all the items amazing
okay so before we end the scrim I do
want to do one more thing because even
though we're getting the value of the
items in here and that's fine but we
also would like the ID because remember
we want to later on make it so that we
can delete these items by pressing on
them and for that we're going to need
the ID so let's just do that now so how
are we supposed to do that now well we
are getting item value here right but if
you look up here this is where we're
actually using this function and we're
feeding this thing to it why don't we
just feed it the current item which
contains both pieces of information
right and then deal with that down here
let's do that now so let's do current
item put it in here and then we'll go
inside of here and we'll say let and now
let's do item id item and then zero
and then we'll say light again and then
we'll say item value and then we'll say
item and then of course we want to get
the first one right so we can now delete
this and let's delete this too and let's
change this to be just item instead of
item value and I think that should work
let's run it now so this of course is
still showing the item names which is
good let's change this now to Item ID
just to make sure that that's working
too does that work and we get them
beautiful perfect so I'm going to just
replace it with item value again and
there we go well done we achieved a lot
in the scrim I'll see you in the next
one
okay so how do we go about deleting
items from our Firebase real-time
database let's take a look at this
project that I've got set up here so
here we have the scrimba times a
publication running since 2016 which is
your One-Stop shop for scrimber news and
Beyond actually I like to go as far as
to say that it's the most trusted
publication in Tech but unfortunately
that's not true see with the rise of
skrimba we've been getting a lot more
contributors to the scrimba times and
that's a good thing right well not
always because sometimes we end up
publishing fake news which of course is
very bad and that's not something we
want to stand behind so in order to
combat this problem we've hired fake
news deleters yes we actually have to
hire people to detect the fake news and
delete it and so in order for these
people to do their jobs we need to
create the functionality for them so how
would that work exactly so here I
basically gone ahead and written all of
the code for this almost all the code
and here you can see we've got some
stories three per row and so we want to
make it so that fake news deleters can
double click any of these items and
delete them from the database alright so
where exactly are we supposed to write
the code let's scroll down here and
right in here is where we're going to be
writing most of our code as you can see
we have double click event right here we
have a function that's going to be
executed anytime any of these are
clicked so what's the first step how do
we go about doing this let's have a look
at the database here we have the
database with all of the stories and the
IDS for it in this case I manually added
the IDS myself just to make it a little
bit simpler for us but it would work
exactly the same with the automatically
generated Firebase IDs okay so if we
wanted to tell Firebase hey delete this
story right here we would need to tell
it delete the story that has the ID ns0
that does make sense because it's a
unique ID right so let's do the first
step which would just be literally to
console log that ID let's do console log
and where's that ID can we see it
anywhere there is Story ID let's try
that put this in here run this and if we
double clicked any of these we get the
ID perfect does it work for all of them
looks like it amazing all right so
what's the next step well the next step
is a little bit more tricky because in
order to delete this story with this ID
we need to give it the exact location so
it's not just the ID but the fact that
it's inside of the news stories inside
of the database we need to give it the
full path to that so remember references
the ref function that we used before
that's what we're going to be using so
let's do that down here so let's delete
this now and I'm going to make a
variable for this let's call it exact
location of story in DB and equal that
to be ref first and then always we got
it provided with the database first so
let's do database and then this is where
we got a point to the location so in
here we're going to need the ID but
before that we're also going to need
this one right hear the news stories
reference and so let's let's put that in
now let's do new stories and then let's
do one of these IDs now let's just test
it out now with ns0 I see if that works
or not ns0 okay is this by itself gonna
do anything no this is just the location
we actually got to remove it from the
database and for that we need the remove
function which is fairly simple to use
so we're just going to go up here and
import it from Firebase first remove
let's go down here again and we're gonna
do remove and we're literally just going
to feed it this whole thing which
contains everything that it needs so at
this point if we run this now and double
click on any of the new stories this
first story should be deleted let's test
that out okay is the first story of fake
news scrimba gets acquired by Microsoft
for 11 billion that's definitely fake
news that's way too little money for
scramba so we're going to delete that
double click and delete it perfect it
works okay so what's the last step now
well we got to make sure that this I ID
is just replaced with whatever ID we're
going to be using for that specific news
story so let's use template strings for
this go down here make it into a back
tick and then we're going to say which
one do we want to use we want to use
this ID right so let's just replace it
in there okay hopefully it works now so
let's run this again and delete all the
fake news okay let's see what we have
here 89 year old becomes oldest scrimba
student to get hired that's definitely
not fake news that's amazing news
scrimber releases first course entirely
made by AI definitely fake news let's
double click on that Elon Musk welcome
16 child to the world that's not fake
news uh this one is that fake news now
ask not fake news either and this is not
fake news either I think we're good now
all right just to recap really quickly
the two main things that we needed to do
was to get the exact location of the
item that we wanted to remove from the
database and then just feed that
information to the remove Firebase
function and then it takes care of the
rest and how does it up update
instantaneously well remember we're
using that on value function that takes
care of that right because deleting
something from the database also updates
it which means that on value gets new
information which it runs okay I hope
that was clear I'll see you in the next
one
all right this is exciting because we're
finally ready to add the code that
removes items from the database when we
click them in the app okay so we know by
now that the key information that we
need is the ID of the item in the
database so let me actually give you a
challenge let's scroll down to this
function right here and right here is
where I want you to add an event
listener to new l so that you can
console log the item when any of these
buttons are pressed that's the first
step pause here try it out for yourself
and I'll be right back good luck
okay how did it go let's try it together
so let's start with new L and then we
want to add event listener we've done
this a million times before first of
course is the event that we're listening
for that's going to be a click and then
we got to write the function in here
let's open that up and of course first
step is always to just console.log I
personally find that the easiest to
start with so what do we want to put in
here though the ID of the item do we
have that already indeed we do we have
it up here so let's just copy that and
put that in right here and let's run
this now to test it out
okay what do we want to remove from here
let's remove the salad click and we got
this console logged is that the same one
yep that's the same one right here pnb
is what it ended on so we know that's
right perfect well done okay what's next
so let's go inside of here and this is
where I actually want to give you the
Second Challenge and that is make a let
variable and call it exact location of
item in DB
and set it equal to ref that's the
function that we're importing right up
here we've already used it here before
and so we want to use it again because
we want to get the exact location of the
item before we can run the remove
function on it so you want to set it
equal to this and then first of course
this database as always and then there
is something and you are supposed to
figure out what that something is
supposed to be so pause here try it out
for yourself and I'll be with you in
just a second
okay I hope that went well let's do it
together now let's go in here and say
exact location of item in DB
set that equal to ref and of course ref
always requires you to specify the
database so let's do database
and then in here what are we supposed to
put in here well let's take a look at
our database right now so right now
we've specified this is the database
that we're dealing with now what other
things that we need to specify well we
first need to say we're inside of the
shopping list and inside this is the ID
that we want to take away or this one or
this one or whichever one that we're
clicking on right so we got to start
with this first so let's go in here and
I'm going to use backticks so let's
start with that and then do shopping
list and then we want to do just slash
and then this is where the ID goes now
do we have the ID again we do have that
because we just used it right up here
let's just copy that and put it right in
here of course using the dollar sign in
here and there we go I think this is
going to work the last thing we got to
do is to actually use the remove
function and that's where you come in
because this is going to be your last
challenge for this Grim use the remove
function to remove the item from the
database pause here try it out for
yourself and I'll be right back good
luck
all right so before we can use this
function we gotta import it from up here
so let's go ahead and say remove
and then we'll go down here
and we just got to call it like this and
all it takes is the exact location of
the item in the database which we
already have so we're just going to feed
it that information and that should take
care of it so let's run this now and
test it out let's try to delete
something or should we delete let's go
ahead and delete the salad
click and delete it gone perfect great
job
so I don't know if you've noticed but
there is a big bug that we haven't
looked at yet try to pause the scrim
right here to figure it out here's a
Hint it has something to do with the
database items so try to remove the
items from the database I'll see you
soon
so did you spot it let's have a look at
it together so let's start off by
deleting the database items one by one
okay we're fine so far let's continue
thank you
okay so now we're down to the last item
let's click on it
aha we got an error let's have a closer
look at that okay let's minimize the
mini browser we got a huge warning here
and then it says here cannot convert
undefined or null to object hmm what's
going on here let's close the console
and I want you to pause the scrim right
here again to try to think about it for
yourself before we look at it together
what is really going on here okay pause
here and I'll see you in just a sec
all right so we got to do some detective
work here first of all which code is
being executed whenever we press the
button to delete it from the database
well that's of course going to be this
code right here right remember whenever
the database has changed this runs every
time but in this case did it really run
it gave us an error and it did that on
the last item what's so special about
that one well see when we deleted the
last item Red Bull in this case with it
we also deleted the shopping list
reference and when the reference no
longer exists this on value function
fails which means that at that point we
don't get back a snapshot because no
snapshot exists okay so how do we handle
that well I can tell you that you don't
need to stress about this at all because
the awesome people at Firebase of course
already thought about this which is why
they provided us with a method called
snapshot dot exists which returns a true
or false Boolean value based on if there
is a snapshot or not okay so armed with
this method I want to give you a
challenge change the on value code so
that it uses snapshot.exists to show the
items when there are items in the
database and if there are no items it
should show the text no items here dot
dot dot yet okay pause here try it out
for yourself and I'll be with you in
just a few moments good luck
okay I hope that went well let's have a
look at it together okay we're using the
snapshot method which is returning a
true or false value whenever I hear that
I immediately think of an if statement
let's start with that let's go up here
and let's say snapshot dot exists okay
this is going to return as true or false
in the case of true that means that
there is a snapshot which means that
there is at least one item in the
database so I'm going to open this thing
up here and I'm gonna put all of this
code inside of there so let's cut it
from here and put it right in here let's
make sure that we indent it properly
there we go now the else Clause of
course is going to be when it's false
which means there are no items in the
database and so in that case what we
want to do well we want to show the text
no items here yet okay so which element
is it that we want to change let's go up
here isn't that shopping list L that's
the one that's the one showing all the
elements so let's just copy that one and
put it right in here and here we can
just use inner HTML that's going to be
the easiest and let's just say no items
here dot dot dot yet okay let's run this
now and now it shows this perfect now
let's test it out by adding another item
here let's add some honey
and there we go beautiful let's delete
it again and we go back perfect great
job
so we have to once again take a little
pause here so that I can acknowledge how
awesome you are seriously you've been
doing an amazing job and we're so close
to being done and I can't wait to see
your project when it is done so now we
only need to add a little bit of CSS to
finish our app now of course we'll need
to do a couple more things before we're
finally done but as far as the core code
for the app is concerned this is it so
here's my next challenge for you add
these two hover effects when you hover
over the add to cart button and all the
items right here another thing is that
when you hover over you see how it turns
into a mickey mouse cursor make that
happen too now let's have a look at the
CSS file because you're gonna need two
color hex codes one for the add to cart
and one for the items and I've included
both of them here now one thing I want
to do before I let you start this
challenge is do you see how these item
colors are black and not dark brown
let's change that I forgot to do that
earlier
there we go perfect so pause here and
make this happen good luck
all right I hope that went well let's
start with the first one so I'm going to
copy this thing I'm going to all the way
down here
and under button I'm going to say button
when it's the hover State what do we
want to do we want to change the
background color to this and then we
want to do cursor pointer as well let's
see if that works
hover over and beautiful works perfectly
let's do the same thing for the other
one copy it from up here
go down to the UL
and Li this is the one but we want to do
it when it's hovered
so hover and then again put this in here
and then again cursor and pointer that
should do it let's see and it works
amazing great job
the deeper you get into development the
more you'll realize that as a coder you
literally have to think about everything
even the smallest things let me give you
an example here we have a simple project
that displays how many cookies you've
given the Cookie Monster at any given
moment so let's run this thing so it
starts off with an empty plate and in
order to give cookies you just press
this text there we go let's give him a
couple
see everything is fine when you go slow
but what inevitably happens when you
have this over to an actual person is
that they start going super fast and
when you do that
this happens see
you start selecting and deselecting the
text and in some cases you can even
select everything like this okay so how
do we fix this well it turns out that
there is a CSS property that fixes this
let's go over to the CSS file this
property is called user select and it's
super simple to use you can either tell
it to select nothing or everything so
let's go inside of the H1 and tell it to
select nothing let's say user select and
then none okay let's test it out again
okay pressing super fast now see
it is not able to select the text
now here's the thing about user select
you can just have it inside of the H1 or
you can actually put it inside of the
container or even the HTML in the body
so at this point you can still select
and deselect the image so what I
normally like to do is to just put this
thing inside of here and that takes care
of everything but just so you know you
can narrow it down to whatever you like
okay let's try it out once more
beautiful
okay time for a little story and for
this story we need to get inside of the
DeLorean Let's Travel back to the early
2000s those were simpler times internet
adoption was growing insanely fast it
was an exciting time to be alive there
was no YouTube Spotify or Facebook I
kind of missed those times but what
definitely didn't exist back then was
this thing right here nope back then if
you wanted to get on the internet you
pretty much could only do it from a
desktop computer laptops existed but
they weren't that powerful so for the
people making apps and websites they
knew that their projects would be
consumed on one type of display simple
right now let's get back to our time how
is it for us now well now we have so
many different devices it's hard to keep
track of all of them and all of them
have different sizes see the people that
wrote HTML back in the day didn't think
about this and so what they decided to
do is that if a website would be shown
on a smaller screen they would just
shrink the website to fit the display
like here and while this works for
monitor displays it completely breaks
down if you're on a mobile display
because this website will look like this
on a phone okay so how do we fix this
luckily there's a very easy way to fix
this we just need to explicitly tell the
browser not to shrink the website but
rather use the width of something called
the viewport to be the device with
instead if you'd like to read more about
this feel free to click on this link and
so there isn't really much for me to
show you in this scrim all we got to do
is go inside of here and paste in this
code now I would like to link to this
excellent YouTube video by Kevin Powell
if you want a better understanding of
this I would recommend you to watch this
video you can click on this to open it
up in a new tab and so that's it for
this one
okay we're in the home stretch now in
this one we want to do two things
firstly what can happen sometimes is
that if we press too fast on the screen
we might accidentally select the text or
even the image now this is a common
problem that happens but luckily there
is a simple fix for this in fact that's
my challenge for you make it so that you
can't select anything on the app pause
here try it out for yourself and I'll be
right back
okay I hope that went well I'm gonna go
inside of here and just say user
select
none and there you go see it removed it
from here so now you can try as much as
you want but you can't select anything
perfect okay what's next well this isn't
something that we're gonna be able to
recreate in the scrimba mini browser but
what happens is that unless we add a
very crucial piece of code inside of our
head tag this app is not going to look
very good on a mobile device it's going
to be shrunken which is something that
we obviously need to fix now I never
seem to remember the exact code for this
so I always Google it so let me actually
give you a challenge right here so the
challenge is add that code that makes
this app look proper on a mobile display
pause here see if you can figure it out
and I'll be right with you
okay I hope you got that so I actually
went on Google and found the w3schools
page for it and I just copied the code
from there and I'm going to paste it
right in here there we go that's the one
well done I'll see you in the next one
have you ever noticed that when you use
a browser every website has an icon up
here yeah well that's called a fav icon
and it's definitely something that you
should spend time on adding to your
website okay so first you got to make
sure that you have an icon this is a
cute image I found that we can use as an
example and an icon in this case is
really just an image now do make sure
that it's a square image and also make
sure that it's in a PNG format I've
included this image for you inside of
the assets folder so you can try it out
for yourself now once you've got your
image ready you want to head over to
fabicon.io and press on the PNG to Ico
button just press this image to get to
the website then you want to drag and
drop your image right here there we go
it shows up here then go ahead and press
the download button that's going to
download a zip file which you can unzip
and there you'll find all of the files
you'll need I've already gone ahead and
added those files to our project here
and now we're going to need to install
this onto our website which which really
just means to copy this code and paste
it into the head tag of our HTML so go
ahead and copy this and you want to
paste this right inside of the
index.html file and put it under the
title tag
now technically as long as you have it
inside of the head tags anywhere it's
going to be fine now unfortunately
because of the limitations of scrimba I
can't really show you how this looks in
this scrim but if you're doing this
locally you can preview the website in a
browser and you'll see the results of it
okay now check this out this service
gives you some extra options so you have
some variations of the image you'll
notice that we have several image files
that we've downloaded now why is that
well this is just so that the image
quality is the best that it can be on
different devices okay and then you
might ask yourself what is this file
right here
site.webmanifest well this is the
magical file that's going to let us show
our icon on the home screen of our
phones as if our web app was actually a
native mobile app but more on that in
another Square
we're getting so close to finishing this
thing now we got to make sure that this
app has an icon so that we can see it on
a tab header in a browser but more
importantly so that we can put that icon
on our phone home screen to launch the
app so this is the image that we'll be
using and I've actually included this
inside of the assets folder add to
cart.png now we're not going to use that
image directly we're actually going to
use the service
fabicon.io to generate all the stuff we
need so open that up on your side you
can press this image to open up the web
page and then press on the PNG to Ico
converter then you want to just drag and
drop the image here and then go ahead
and press the download button that's
going to download a zip file which you
want to unzip and you'll find all the
files you'll need in there I've actually
already gone ahead and added those to
our project right here now the final
thing we need to do is to scroll down a
bit on the page and copy this code right
here to install this thing so let's go
ahead and add that right inside of the
head tag and then that thing perfect now
because of how scrimbo works I can't
really show you how this looks but
you'll see the difference if you're
working locally in your browser now you
might notice that there is a file right
here as well site.webmanifest we're
going to talk about that in just a
little bit
so remember when you made a Chrome
extension with pad earlier in this
module remember there was a manifest.js
file let's pull that up now what exactly
is this thing well in the case of a
Chrome extension this file tells Chrome
the information it needs to hook this
program into Chrome so things like the
name the version number the icon the
description now all this data turns into
this inside of the extensions manager in
Chrome now similarly there is a web
manifest file that we can make when we
want to turn our web app into something
that looks and feels like a mobile app
now the fancy word for this is a pwa or
a progressive web app now let's go into
the project to take a closer look so
here I have a project set up that's
called the cat app and all it does when
you run it is show a random picture of a
cat and these pictures are actually
generated by an AI so all these pictures
are being fetched from this website
called this cat does not exist.com okay
so on the left side I have a
site.webmanifest file here now look at
this this looks completely messed up but
the only reason for that is because
there's no spacing and no indentation so
now I actually have a challenge for you
pause the scrim right here and add the
appropriate spacing and indentation to
make this look more like a JavaScript
object something that you're used to
okay good luck I'll be right back
alright I hope that went well I'm just
going to paste the solution here there
we go this looks much better now what do
we have going on here so first we got
the name and then we got the short name
let's go in and say cat app for both of
those cat app and then here we have the
icons this is what's going to pop up on
our home screen so these are images that
we already have in our project of course
generated by that five icon.io service
and then we have the theme color now
this color right here is something that
you can control and let me show you
where that is visible so that color is
going to be popping up right at the top
here I have it turned to Red so it's
easily visible so I like to just set
this color to be the background color
that we're using in the app okay now
what is this background color well this
is the color that's going to be visible
before the styles for your web app have
been loaded so if it takes a while to
load them this is what's going to be
showing okay now finally what is this
display it's set to Standalone and so
this will make the app look like a
standalone application so any extra
things that the browser has is going to
take that away so it looks and feels
like a native mobile app now there's
actually a lot more to the web manifest
file than what I showed you I can't
cover everything in this scrim feel free
to click on this page right here and
read more about all the things that are
possible but for our use case this is
plenty
we're finally ready for the very last
step can you believe it you made it here
one tiny little thing and we're gonna be
done with this bad boy so exciting okay
let's do this so let's open up the site
web manifest file and I want to give you
a challenge right here pause the scrim
and fix this thing up so it looks better
that means ad spacing and indentation
I'll wait for you
okay I hope that went well I'm just
gonna paste this in there we go much
better let's start filling in the
information here so the name of course
is going to be add to cart and let's
just copy this and paste it right in
here the icons are already set the theme
color we want to set to the background
color here so let's just fetch that from
the CSS let's go here and copy this one
right here we'll put that in for both
theme color and actually background
color as well there we go and display we
want to just keep on Standalone and
we're finally done
can you believe it you just finished
building your first app oh my God I hope
you're proud of yourself because I
certainly am seriously take a moment and
give yourself a pat on the back also
make sure to celebrate this very special
moment hopefully you're more excited
than this guy seriously though amazing
job now the only thing that's left for
you to do is to deploy your project
using netlify and we're going to do that
in the next script but before we go
ahead and deploy the app I want to take
a little pause here to briefly talk
about something very important and that
is that you should spend a little bit of
time personalizing your app because
otherwise your app is going to look
exactly the same as mine and probably
the same as a lot of other scrimba
students now let me show you how easy it
can be to give your app a personal Flair
so this is what we have right now let's
change the image of the cat that's
looking pretty good let's do another one
okay not quite there yet there we go
that's the one okay what about the font
let's change it to another one okay okay
let's keep going one more and there it
is all right what about colors let's
change it up a bit okay looking pretty
good how about adding a little bit of
contrast there we go see how just a few
minor changes can make these two look
pretty different so make sure to
personalize your app so that you really
feel that the app is showing who you are
and I know it takes a little bit of time
to do this but it adds that little extra
you know
drum roll please
because it's finally time for us to
deploy our app to netplify Let's jump
into it right away so of course the
first thing we got to do is to make sure
that all of the project files are inside
of a folder on our machine so if you
have been following along with me on
scrimba this entire time then you want
to go ahead and download the files as a
zip now you probably already know how to
do that but just in case you forgot you
want to press on this button right here
and then we want to go up here to
download a zip press on that and there
we go we're downloading this ZIP file on
our machine then you of course want to
go ahead and unzip that file on your
computer at which point you're going to
get this folder with a very weird name
where all of your files are now you want
to go ahead and rename that to something
like add to cart there we go now if
you've been following Along on your
local machine this entire time then of
course you already have a project folder
alright this part is done now now we
need to head over to netflixy you can go
ahead and press the screenshot if you
want to open up netlify on your end okay
so I'm going to quickly go up here and
login I'm going to use email to log in
but please feel free to use whichever
account is best for you and for a lot of
you that's probably going to be your
GitHub account okay let's go ahead and
log in and then you should see something
like this now we want to scroll down a
little bit until we see this now down
here is where it says you can drag and
drop your folder which is exactly what
we're going to be doing so just go ahead
and drag and drop your folder here there
we go now it's going to take a couple of
seconds and then boom it's done now I
want to take a little bit of time to
appreciate this moment because I've been
deploying my projects for a very long
time now and I remember a time when this
whole process used to take several hours
sometimes even several days and we just
did all of that with just a simple drag
and drop truly magical okay anyway now
our app is finally deployed now we want
to go into the site settings to rename
our app so just press right here and
then we want to scroll down a little bit
there we go and then press change site
name so I'm going to change it from this
very random name to something a little
bit more appropriate there we go much
better then go ahead and press save
perfect and that's it now we can go
ahead and press this URL to open it up
in a new tab oh yes look at that beauty
that's our app which is now live for the
entire world just like that amazing job
now in the next screen we're going to do
the very final step which is to put this
bad boy on our phone home screens see
you in just a bit
it is finally time for us to put our
beautiful creation on our precious phone
okay let's get right into it so this
scrim is going to be split into two
first I'm going to show you the steps on
how to put your app on your phone if you
have an Android then we'll do the iPhone
okay first thing you want to do is to
open up the default browser on your
phone which for Android of course is
Google Chrome once you've opened up
Chrome you want to write down the exact
netlify URL for your app there we go and
there it is now go ahead and press this
button to open up the menu then you want
to go all the way down to where it says
add to home screen press on that then
it's going to ask you if you want to
change the display name I don't want to
do that so I'm going to just go ahead
and press add and boom the app is now
added to the very last position of all
the apps so if you have a lot of apps on
your phone you just gotta go to the very
last page there it is right there once
you've found the app just move it to a
more appropriate position I'm going to
move it to my first screen perfect now
let's finally open it up oh my god do
you see it looks exactly like a native
app go ahead and try it out alright
let's do it for the Apple people now so
again we want to open up the default
browser of the system which in the case
of Apple is Safari then we want to put
in the URL of the app right here there
we go and there it is and then we want
to press this button right here it's
going to open up the menu we want to go
down to where it says add to home screen
press on that and then it's going to ask
us to set the display name of this I'm
going to just keep it to add to cart
press add and boom there we go there it
is okay now for the moment of truth
let's open it up and there we go do you
see it looks and feels exactly like a
mobile app and there you have it that
was the very last step you made it
you know the best part about finishing a
project being able to share it with the
world and that's exactly what I want you
to do if you're comfortable with it of
course now there are two platforms that
are perfect for sharing this kind of
thing Twitter and Linkedin so the first
thing you need is to get a great
screenshot of your app like this one
best to do it from your phone and if you
want to spend the extra time you can
even make a video or a gif then just
write a tweet or a post about you
finishing this course and showing off
your awesome creation like Brian has
done here with the scrimbuff project
that he finished on LinkedIn this one's
from James and this one's from Bianca
this is Oscar's finished app on Twitter
this one's by sushant and here's another
one
now apart from being able to share your
creations with other people my favorite
thing about this is that you're
documenting something that you did in
your life now imagine how good you're
gonna feel looking back at this in three
five or ten years especially compared to
what kind of Hardcore stuff you're gonna
be working on then so definitely share
your wins with the world and remember to
tag me and scrim by in it that way I'm
going to get a sweet notification and I
can give you a like and a comment to
show you some love alrighty the very
last thing I want to say is this if you
have any feedback at all for me then I'd
love to hear it this is scrimba's first
course on Firebase but we think it's an
awesome technology and would love to
create more courses going forward so if
you have anything at all to share on
that let me know the best way to reach
me is to tweet at me or DM me on Twitter
or you can also send me a message on
LinkedIn that's all for this one thank
you so much for listening
can you believe it you did it you just
finished this entire project I am so so
so happy for you right now seriously do
make sure to do something very nice for
yourself after you're done watching the
scrim because what you've just achieved
is no small thing amazing amazing job
okay we gotta do a little recap before I
let you go so the first thing we looked
at was import now what was that so we
wanted certain functionality from
Firebase which we just imported in the
form of functions so these are the
things that we imported from this
location and then here this is where all
of the code was and we only got certain
things that we needed and then we
covered the initialize app function from
Firebase which we use down here to
initialize the app using the database
URL and that is just so we have an app
object to work with in our project this
is what sets everything up then we use
the get database function right in here
we created a database object using the
get database function and fed it the app
object that we just made this is still
part of the setup that we did and then
we used the reference function remember
in a Firebase real-time database
everything is a reference and so we
needed to make a shopping list reference
where all of the shopping list items
would be saved then we use the push
function from Firebase which was a super
simple function right here to First say
that we wanted to push a new thing at
this reference and then we just fed it
the value and that was it and then we
finally came to the magical on value
function which is where we wrote a lot
of the code so this on value function
just sits here and listens for changes
in the database and whenever a change
happens it gets a new snapshot which it
uses to run this code all over again and
so that was the snapshot of course and
then we talked a little bit about IDs
because in software development IDs are
super important and so as we saw in our
realtime database every single item has
to have a unique ID then then using that
unique ID we could remove a database
item which is what we did right here we
got the exact location of the item in
the database and then we just ran the
remove function on it we also looked at
how we can transform objects into arrays
which is what we needed to do inside of
the on value function so that we could
actually write a for loop on the array
that is what we did right up here and
then of course we used create element
instead of inner HTML because we
realized inner HTML wasn't powerful
enough to do what we wanted it to do
which is why we wrote this function
where we created a new element and then
we gave it some text content and then we
made sure that we ran some code whenever
you press on that button and then we
appended it to the parent element and
then of course we looked at Flex wrap a
flexbox feature which let us wrap these
elements around like this and we also
looked at the Gap feature in flexbox
that led us very easily create this gap
between the items then we used user
select to make it that the user couldn't
unintentionally select parts of the app
which is just a much better user
experience then we added a crucial line
of HTML to set the viewport this one
right here which made it so that the
width of the app would be correct on
mobile devices then of course we added a
5 icon using that service favicon.io it
added all of these images as well and
then of course the final thing was the
web application manifest file right here
which made it possible for us to
transform our web application to look
like a native app on our phones oh boy
when you list it out like that it looks
like so much stuff and so finally I like
to say Well done on completing this
section
[Music]
what is